Schengen is only across the water from
Hong Kong but has experienced none of
its chaos something may be coming though
satellite pictures appeared to show
Chinese armored personnel carriers and
other vehicles gathering in a stadium
here on the mainland there could be more
than 500 in total and the US President
himself appeared to back that assessment
tweeting that troops were being moved to
the Chinese border
[Music]
it tallies with what Chinese propaganda
has been showing its citizens and the
world
a show of might where the soundtrack is
bombastic as a film score it is ominous
and it has prompted fears of a brutal
Tiananmen Square like crackdown in Hong
Kong Beijing sees no really good options
right now which is why we're seeing them
position themselves to either take it an
approach of more aggressive action
whether that's military a political or
find a way to essentially disintegrate
or untangle the the movement Beijing has
repeatedly said that Hong Kong is a
problem for Hong Kong its government
should sort it out the recent attacks on
symbols of Chinese power have riled
authorities on the mainland
and so it's propaganda has become
noticeably more strident laying the
rhetorical ground for intervention
this video shows soldiers of the
People's Liberation Army in the Hong
Kong garrison conducting riot
suppression exercises pointedly giving
commands in Cantonese the main language
of hong kong for now videos like these
are probably only a warning to
protesters few regimes signal imminent
military operations with social media
posts and it's also an important message
to the domestic audience throughout
china chaos over the water but control
on the mainland here in shenzhen it
doesn't feel like a city ready for a
mass mobilization that could change but
Beijing will hold off for as long as it
can it's a last resort sending in
military or paramilitary forces would
mean the end of the Hong Kong protests
but also be the beginning of something
much more unpredictable on a global
scale through its rhetoric Beijing has
been relatively patient with Hong Kong
we don't know though when that patients
may run out the mayor thought is deeply
whirring Tom Cheshire Sky News surgeon